sometimes it comes yeah he's got two
waters down yeah he slammed two waters
this uh this shooting happening while
he's on is so appropriate I mean it's so
crazy that that's this is the time so
this is a newsroom why do they have a
motivation for this guy no motivation is
being interrogated right now is what I
just read and it's amazing that these
guys want they get captured but they
don't get killed like the Parkland kid
and a lot of these people like how are
they not killing these people when
they're when it's happening supposedly
oh my kindness twice is it some fake
news thing I mean he shot reporters you
know until the interrogation comes out I
feel like it's not fair to Ron Cey but
there are people pointing at things that
have been in the news recently oh [ __ ]
it's just so much I mean I hear what Ted
saying that you should be able to defend
yourself and I agree like if you were in
a grocery store somewhere and some guy
came in shooting and you had a gun I
would want you to be able to defend
yourself you know I want you to be alive
I agree with you I get that
but that's is that the only way I mean
or is it's just what we have to do right
now I mean I don't know what anybody on
the other side wants other than taking
away everyone's guns but if you take
away everyone's guns how are you
possibly gonna do an audit of 300
million guns in this country how are you
gonna find all the illegal ones how you
gonna find all the stored ones and then
there's that old cliche if you outlaw
guns only outlaws will have guns I mean
it's almost like the same thing we're
talking about when in in terms of
legalizing and illegal illegal drugs and
when drugs are legal they can be taxed
and you can make sense of the situation
you can have treatment centers the
stigma of you know the the appeal of
them of doing something you're not
supposed to do is no longer there and
then you're not funding these illegal
organizations organizations like you
know the cartels in Mexico or back when
it was organized crime in America for
alcohol when the prohibition was going
on it's I don't think that you're gonna
be able to take away all these guns but
I don't know what the argument I would
like to talk to somebody who has an
argument that you could do it because I
know they did it in Australia but
Australia is so small
and by the way you can get guns in
Australia people use guns they're for
hunting all the time so guns are
available and occasionally they do have
gun violence but they had like one mass
shooting in the 1990s in Australia and
they just banned all the guns but
Australians are there a different
culture to like this [ __ ] culture is
gun happy from all of our movies and
television shows and the solution is
always like bang bang bang like shooting
people is a part of the solution you
know I don't know I don't know man I
just no one has an answer didn't no one
on that side no one on this side every
answer has holes in it you laughing what
happened I always say to you know this
is conversation about guns you know and
and I don't see an answer I do I really
don't I don't see an answer the
ultimately will be like I'm all for a
responsible gun ownership I have guns of
hunted guns
I believe in gun ownership
but how do you stop gun violence and I
don't know I don't know what the answer
is and I think this is ultimately with
everybody is trying to find we were
talking about when you were gone the
Australians where they they banned guns
because of one mass shooting and they've
never had a mass shooting since
yeah but then crime continues to go up
and down based on other social factors
so and there's not many of them there's
only 20 million people in their entire
country you know I would like to address
probably the glaring beast in the room
of America you're 50 something right
fifty fifty fifty one and art I'll be 70
and I've had a pretty good radar
I've got a pretty good absorption factor
of information evidence experiences
ideas opinions activities
what the hell happened that would allow
Americans so many of us to become so
evil that we want to hurt each other and
kill each other and kill children rob
and and molest they want to make the
biggest impact they want to hurt the
most people because they're hurting